hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV I'm
joined by Matt Welch my colleague at
Reason magazine and today we're talking
with John Mackey the co-founder and CEO
of Whole Foods Market John thanks for
coming thanks for having me you in
August penned an op-ed in the Wall
Street Journal outlining the Whole Foods
medical plan and this caused an enormous
stir and a season where we're talking
about healthcare reform why do we need
health care reform and why should the
government not be as big a part of Gov
health care the current system the way
it's structured and regulated is
becoming increasingly more and more
expensive and we've gone from spending
four percent of our gross domestic
product on health care in 1960 to almost
17 percent today and the trend lines
aren't really slowing down so it's
becoming increasingly expensive for the
whole society and so that I think that's
what's driving the need for health care
reform so then why why should the
government get out of health care
because government spends about half of
every health care I don't think I
suggested that government get out of
health care but that rather than as you
say they spend almost 50% of all the
health care dollars the other 50% they
don't spend they highly regulate I think
that we need to empower individuals in
such a way and empower markets I think
that's a better way to drive down the
cost of health care for all of us do you
think employer-based health care is a
right or is even a good idea I'm not
sure that's the best way to do it
primarily because as long as you work
for Whole Foods we got this great health
insurance program but what if you want
to leave what if you get a better job
offer someplace else oh you're ready to
do something else you can't take it's
not portable you can't take Whole Foods
plan with you so that restrains people
from maybe leaving they're not sure they
can get as good a health care program
and so I don't think it's the best way
we could do it make me better if
individuals did it themselves
can you talk a little bit about your
sort of politics how you would describe
them how they originated just
political philosophy I believe in
capitalism I believe in markets I
believe in an individual's individual
empowerment an individual individual
choice so that's my philosophy of
politics and capitalism one the 20th
century I mean the battle between
communism and capitalism as a basic
economic system
are we still winning or are we
floundering in in the wake of that big
Viktor again I think as I think we won
but we didn't people didn't come to love
capitalism because I don't think we've
articulated well we haven't made people
conscious of what capitalism is and all
the good things that it does it's always
on the defensive it's always Malhar
always attacking it for being greedy and
selfish and only caring about money all
you care about is money we've created
this wall in the world between on the
one hand we believe that not-for-profits
and government are motivated by a deeper
purpose public service and then on the
other hand side of this wall we have
corporations and businesses and they're
motivated strictly by selfishness and
greed and frankly most young idealistic
people are more drawn towards the one
that's not motivated strictly by
selfishness do you have any political
team that you particularly root for a
political team it's funny that you would
say that I think part of that
polarization that exists in America is
that people try to size you up for what
team you're on if you're on their team
they love you and if you're on the other
team they hate you I believe people need
to think for themselves and so I don't
feel I come on any of those teams did
you vote in the 2008 election I did yeah
who did you vote for I voted for a Bob
Barr Libertarian candidate I was a you
know electron Paul but he didn't get the
Republican nomination regretfully right
well thank you John I want to thank John
Mackey of Whole Foods for talking with
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie with Matt
Welch